[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari sol and
i'm a pianist composer coming from the
classical music world since recently
i've been trying to explore a bunch of
different genres beyond what i'm
familiar with and this week i decided to
focus on the blues especially the 12 bar
progression that stems from the genre
so i've been introduced to the blues
form on several occasions in the past
few years but i never really sat down
and tried to apply it in any way
okay so i don't have my umbrella
as always
here are some things i learned if not
reinforced my knowledge on
the following is the basic 12 bar blues
progression in the case of the major
blues form the 1 and 4 chords are
usually dominant 7th chords and for the
minor blues form minor 7th chords there
are many altered blues forms stemming
from this basic model and variations of
this progression exist as a standard
form across many types of genres
including jazz rock country pop etc
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
the people who
[Music]
two of the most common blues scales are
the minor blues scale
[Music]
and the major blues scale
[Music]
these are both pentatonic scales with an
added blue note
[Music]
i also learned a lot from transcribing
parts of one of oscar peterson's
performances of sea jam blues
this was really helpful for me in
understanding subtle mannerisms in his
playing that you really can't get just
by looking at a written out
transcription all right so it's been a
couple of days since i started this
transcription
i have been writing it all out i'm
almost done
and i'm working on the left hand it's
really hard for me to hear because i'm
new to this language
but it's been fun and it's been
especially fun trying to listen to all
of the places where oscar peterson
really makes an accent
and i've been marking those as well
something like this
let me see
if i were to look at it
normally speaking i would just play it
with these fingers
and then because my fourth finger is
here i would just use it
but because of the accenting i find it
much more
much more practical to
repeat
the finger so repeat the third finger
[Music]
it's much easier to
make that separation on and also the
accent
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so i feel slightly strange walking into
a mall
with a keyboard
but
and of course in line with the tradition
of these sound bake videos i wrote a
pocket piece
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
the chords i used were c7 for four bars
f7 for two
c7 for two
an a flat major seventh chord
a c minor over b flat
[Music]
and a c7 for two bars
just for fun i also tried playing a
version with a little more of a swing
feel to it
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
by the way thank you so much to everyone
who responded to my posts both on
youtube and instagram about finding
tunes to add to my playlist
don't feel like shopping
you